it looks like somebody is getting under
their skin the liberal media is loving
some vicious smears against Republican
presidential candidate Nikki Haley
Whoopi Goldberg bashing the governor
over her age
a new generation you're 51 what are you
talking about but it's not a new
generation she may be she may be younger
than most of those people but her
rhetoric is the same she's saying the
same being and right on cue an MSNBC
guest trying to link her to you guessed
it white supremacy to quote Zora Neal
Hurston not all skin folk are Kinfolk
Nikki Haley instead is the Dinesh
D'Souza of Candace Owens she's the alpha
Karen with brown skin and for white
supremacists and racist she's the
perfect Manchurian Candidate but Haley
isn't letting the attacks get her down
I have had this all my life when I was
first elected governor there were some
minority Democrats that said she's not a
minority she's just a conservative with
a tan they will come at me with
everything but you know none of that
phases me if my age is all they have
um it means we're winning
you know Greg I'll come to you on this I
think you're the resident expert on what
uh bad people would say ah very very
much so are racist or terms like racist
and white supremacy are they kind of
overplayed to the point they don't
matter anymore I'll tell you what you
know uh my sources in the white
supremacist movement tell me they're
very upset because once again minorities
are stealing their jobs
so
Chic because they called her a white
Supreme oh my God the silence there was
just brutal I think um I think no one in
that MSNBC segment should feel proud of
what just went on in there because you
have to you have to understand whether
you're having this argument or not you
were talking about pigment it's like
what she said I'm a conservative with a
tan it's like that sounds pretty CR you
know funny and humorous but they're
actually saying you know she's she's
basically a racist with a tan because
she's a conservative they end up in this
spot where they know when they're like
when he was saying that you could tell
it wasn't just untrue it was also
unbelievable it was like you could see
on their faces that here's a nice lady
who's done a lot with her life right
she's you know she's become a governor
she's like she's she's raised her family
she's a good person and you're on TV
basically saying this you know it's not
true you could say the same thing and I
won't say this about these MSNBC
that you know their Brown skins allow
them to profit on MSNBC by the you know
by telling vulnerable they're vulnerable
viewers that everybody's racist I won't
say that you wouldn't do that I would
not do that I would not do that you
would not do that no I would never do
that because that's that would be going
down to their level yeah I won't do that
I hate all of you for not getting my
joke Pierce it's not my fault I'm from
Georgia I don't get most jokes
we live in a world where identity
characteristics like race and gender are
something that can be applauded in one
person say Kamala Harris because of
their beliefs but something you can
attack someone like Nikki Haley who's
arguably more impressive an alpha Karen
with brown skin I mean just think about
that sentence how offensive that is and
also how easily offended they are by
anything even resembling a sentence like
that so once again it's the double
standards and hypocrisy of the work
Brigade but there's also this
extraordinary attack on Nikki Haley for
her age first of all Don Lemon not only
against him other than he stole my
office in CNN when I left
um and called me a racist over Meghan
Markle other than that I have nothing
against him um and I wish him all the
best this week with his comeback but
him mocking Nikki Haley for her age when
he's about six seven years older but
also missing the point I check this
today you'll be pleased with my research
I think that I checked out the age of
every American president in history if
Nikki Haley was to it was to win she
would be in the top third youngest
presidents Americas ever had she would
be six years younger than George
Washington and Thomas Jefferson and a
year younger than Abraham Lincoln so
we're going to start saying that women
of her age are over the hill past their
Prime Whoopi Goldberg giving it large
about it it's like Whoopi if anyone's
past their Prime is somebody who's still
got a job on a TV show having said
publicly twice now that the Holocaust
wasn't about racism well speaking of it
so I mean I just find the way they go
after people so ludicrous anyway
that's my answer speaking of I wanted to
say this for an hour judge speaking of
women who are in their Prime I don't
know a woman in my career that's been
more successful than you you're a
Pioneer in your career is this type of
attack something that it comes with the
territory when it comes being a
successful conservative woman well I
mean at this Point
um you know being a woman is not that's
that that unusual I mean but years ago
when I started and yes I think I'm I'm
certainly I'll leave the number alone
but um
you're rocketing towards your Prime but
as opposed to Don Lemon who's rocketing
the other way but for me there was
always criticism there was always
criticism because I was a woman because
you know I I was a Lebanese descent they
said I was I had my roots deep in the
Arab world I was like no we're
Phoenicians but whatever
um but the truth is these people do not
believe what they're saying they're
alleging that Nikki Haley uses her brown
skin as a weapon against poor Brown folk
I mean they make this stuff up I don't
know how they even live with themselves
except maybe is Greg saying they just
are trying to make money it's a problem
it is a profit model and what you do is
you just steal yourself up against them
you ignore them and you just do better
than they do and you win in the end I
don't know that you know the thing is
the worst thing okay there are two
things that were said today about about
Nikki Haley which one is worse uh your
pastor prime or you're a white
supremacist obviously being called the
white supremacist is the worst thing I
don't think you ever let anybody offer
that I think the reason why CNN it was
imploded in the last couple years years
is because of that because there were
people that were tired of being called
racist by CNN and their viewers were
like screw you they gave him the finger
they're gone I mean CNN's implosion
happened because they opened the doors
to their dismissal once you start
calling people like there's no there's
no more formidable enemy than the
falsely accused yeah oh yeah they know
real quick this is pretty easy question
this is probably good for her moving
forward no she should get fruit baskets
for every single one of them yeah and I
do think did you guys ever do Mad Libs
yes okay so the insults that they were
lobbying at her seemed to me like just
like a Mad Lib thing because they're
talk they're calling this woman who was
the governor who took down the
Confederate flag in South Carolina which
was not easy a white supremacist it's
absurd and there's a debate about you
know should you get into a contest early
and one of the reason is because you
have to staff up you got to raise money
you got to figure out a way to be in the
news every day it's not easy to stay
they have helped her be in the news
every single day so she's just sending
one of those edible flat one of those
things
[Laughter]
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now